We now would like
to analyze the force
law on an idealized spring, a
force law called Hooke's law.
Let's begin by drawing
a ideal spring connected
to an object on a
frictionless surface.
So we'll draw our object.
We'll draw our idealized spring.
This surface here is
going to be frictionless.
And this is a wall, and
we'll draw it like that.
And now what we'd like to do
is to introduce the force law
for a spring, a force law, which
will be called Hooke's law.
So the way we'd
like to analyze this
is by drawing two pictures.
Our first picture
will have the spring
at an equilibrium picture.
So let's draw the
wall again and let's
draw the spring and our object.
And this is called the
equilibrium picture,
so I'll write
equilibrium picture.
And now what we
like to do is draw
a picture, a dynamic picture
at some arbitrary time t
so here we have a dynamic
picture at time t.
And I'll draw it in a second.
So we draw the same
object, and now we're
going to move our object
to some arbitrary position.
In this case, the spring
has been stretched,
wall, frictionless surface.
And now, I'm in position to
choose a coordinate system.
So what I'll do is I'll choose
my origin at the edge right
here, this is called x equal 0.
I'll show it in the
dynamic picture.
And my coordinate
function for the object
here, I'm going to refer
to that as x sub t.
Now, notice that this
coordinate function is also
an indication of how much the
spring has been displaced.
As far as directions
go, we'll have an axis.
And this is our
plus x direction,
so usually we indicate that
with the unit vector i hat.
And now Hooke's law
is the statement
that the force on the spring,
that the force on the object F
is proportional to how much
the object has displaced,
which represents
either the stretching
or the compressing
of the spring.
So it's equal to minus kx I hat.
Now, what does this
minus sign mean?
Well, this is an example of
what we call a restoring force.
And let's look at just
a couple of examples.
When x is positive, that
means that the object
has been pulled out from
the equilibrium position.
The spring is
undergoing tension,
it's being stretched apart.
The molecules in the spring
that constitute the spring
are being pulled apart, and
there's a restoring force
inside the spring.
This is an atomic
force in nature
that's pulling the
spring backwards,
hence exerting a restoring
force on the object.
So this forces in the
minus i hat direction.
It's restoring in
that direction.
I'll draw the force like that.
Now, suppose we
drew another picture
where the object is pushed
in, compressing the spring.
So let's draw once
again a diagram.
And let's show the
spring under compression
from our equilibrium position.
Now here, we have,
again, that x of t.
But in this case,
x of t is negative.
So this is extension, so
we'll call that case A.
And case B, when x is less
than 0, it's under compression.
And then we see
that with x negative
and the additional
minus sign, the force
is in the positive direction.
And so in both
instances, the force
is a restoring force
back to equilibrium.
So the restoring
force, whether you're
under extension or
compression, is pointing,
let's just call it,
is the direction
of the force is towards
the equilibrium position.
And this example of
a restoring force
is also only proportional to x.
And so in that case, we
can add the word linear,
because it's just to
the single power x.
And this is an example of
a linear restoring force.
And this is a model
for an ideal spring.
Now, this constant k is
called the spring constant.
And the units of
the spring constant,
if you divide the units of
force by the units of distance--
so we have SI units
are Newton over meters,
and that's the measure
of the spring constant.
Now, what we'll show next
is an experiment in which we
can figure out how to actually
measure that spring constant k.